[Music]
well 2023 has been another Stellar year
for the BBC collapsing viewing figures
hemorrhaging license fee payers and a
projected budget deficit of 400 million
by 2027 the BBC is like the childhood
sweetheart that you bump into 20 years
later and find out she's got three kids
the years haven't been kind and she's
addicted to crack the BBC used to
produce incredible programming comedies
dramas documentar sports nowadays the
most interesting content the BBC creates
is its presenters demented Behavior
whether it's Gary liner comparing a
conservative government to the Nazis or
news presenter Hugh Edwards sexting 17
year olds Hugh Edwards was one of the
most respected BBC News presenters and a
stor wart of the corporation there was
widespread disappointment in the BBC at
his conduct with a 17-year-old as that's
actually a bit old for their presenters
exactly it's deeply hypocritical for the
BBC to discipline Hugh Edwards for a bit
of alleged digital nonsense when
actually all he was doing was
celebrating BBC culture seriously
outside the BBC headquarters is a
sculpture by Eric Gil who was a
notorious pedophile and abuser the BBC
were asked to take the sculpture down
but they refused because the BBC is
loyal to its Heroes you know your
organization is toxic when all your
presenters have to come out to deny
their announce basically had two weeks
of a celebrity pedo version of guess who
which ironically is the most popular
thing the BBC produced this year but it
wasn't the only Scandal to rock the
organization in 2023 gica compared
conservative politician soel braan to a
Nati because if there's one thing we
know about Hitler is he was a big fan of
brown women who were married to Jews
wanting to stop illegal immigration is
now seen on a part with advocating for
the extermination of the Jewish race
which is weird because the BBC has no
problem with the extermination of the
Jewish race yeah they refused to call
Hamas a terrorist organization despite
the fact that the British government
calls them terrorists and one of their
stated aims is the obliteration of
Israel plus their actions during October
the 7th were a bit terrorist if you know
what I mean veteran BBC news reporter
John Simpson explained why the BBC
refused to call Hamas terrorists and in
his own words it's because I [__]
love him and everything they do to
eliminate the zist pig dogs Francis did
he actually say that well no his
argument was that the BBC's MO is to
present their viewers with the facts
about a particular situation and then
allow the viewers to make up their own
mind in his words we don't take sides
and there was me thinking the BBC no
longer did good comedy because obviously
not taking sides is what they did with
Trump brexit Co climate change
immigration and now the Middle East so
it does look slightly dodgy if you're
prepared to be biased on a highly
contentious issue like brexit but
refusing to label an organization that
committed Mass Slaughter terrorists
couple that with the fact that the
quality of the content has gone downhill
quicker than Hugh Edward's chances of a
second career as a babysitter and things
are looking pretty bleak for a once
beloved institution the cherry on top of
the giant turd that has been 2023 was
BBC News presenter Mario mashiri giving
viewers the at the star of the news
broadcast masheri defended herself by
saying that it was a private joke with
colleagues and she hadn't meant to flip
the bird to the BBC's viewers no one
noticed it originally as all the viewers
were either sleeping or brain dead it's
only because it went viral on Twitter
that the incident started to gain some
traction the conservative party even
tried to write a funny tweet about it
proving yet again that conservatives are
good at many things but there'll always
be rubbish at comedy plus I don't think
the conservative party are in any
position to to be lecturing anyone about
illegal immigration the conservatives
have let more dodgy people in than the
BBC although I doubt many of those men
coming on the boats will raise as much
money for spinal Charities as Jimmy savl
so roll on 2024 when we'll have the UK
general election and the 2024
presidential election in America plenty
of time and opportunity for our beloved
State broadcaster to sink even further
into the Quagmire and with that
goodbye do you remember the Canadian
trucker protest in 2022 where thousands
of Canadians came out to protest covid
restrictions and vaccine mandates now
these protests lasted for weeks and the
people out on the streets needed funds
as any Grassroots protest would so
people set up online crowdfunding
campaigns which raised millions of
dollars incredible but those campaigns
were closed down and the money didn't
get to the protesters because the
Canadian authorities started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure on them to close the
campaigns the biggest crowdfunding
platform the one we've all heard of
completely capitulated to their demands
now this is where our partners give and
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts gien go came
out and said quote we respect diverse
views and believe hope and freedom are
values worth fighting for this is why
we're proud to partner with GIF and go
so if you need to crowdfund for whatever
means the most to you then don't go to
the big Tech platforms we recommend you
do it on gend go starting a campaign on
gend go is easy and intuitive go to giv
send go.com today that's giv send go.com
to start raising money for whatever is
important to you if you enjoyed this
then click here to check out consentin
monologue on the BBC racism
[Music]
scandal